I think chat GPT has stops at collecting
data at 2021 I think but if it carries
on updating the data it's going to be
collecting its own data it's going to be
like it's going to be a feedback that's
the really that's really the biggest
thing that I'm seeing is that if you
project AI very long term it's called
it's going to be diminishing it'll be
diminishing returns and a kind of
you know when people when people talk
about like Singularity and like AI you
know exploding and becoming I don't see
I don't see how that's possible because
it has no relevance it has no desires
and so all it can ultimately be is a
kind of spinning back onto itself with
maybe a with a long Arc but on that long
Arc you're looking at a kind of of
leveling you know a kind of intelligence
leveling I don't see I can't see
otherwise
oh
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everyone uh I'm here with Paula
boddington those of you who've watched
my channel have seen uh us talk on
several subjects she is an ethicist
she's also teaches and different
different institutions and uh she's been
thinking a lot about you know
the relationship between biology and
ethics but also technology and ethics
and so it seems like you know this is
the perfect time to talk about it with
the rising of AI and also the kind of
Madness around self-identification all
of this is kind of happening all at the
same time and so Paula thanks for
talking to me again
oh really great to talk to you uh the
main problem is trying to focus on
something where it doesn't just go all
over the place because everything is so
interconnected yeah well I'd like to
know a little bit about because AI has
now really exploded and we've also not
only has it exploded but the religious
aspect of AI seems to be coming more and
more to the fore you know with Elon Musk
going on the record talking about the
heads of Google literally saying they're
building a God you know and and then
many of the transhumanists you know have
pronounced themselves in Publications
but now it's becoming more and more
obvious that there is a religious aspect
to AI uh even in the people that are
making it and so I don't know if you had
thoughts about where we are now which
igbt taking over really within just to a
few months all of a sudden it's
everywhere okay yeah well I mean I have
lots of I have um there's lots of things
that could be said about this so I'm in
sort of a religious aspect of AI has
been there really for a long time and
and maybe it might be also helpful to
start off by clarifying some things
because there are a lot of people who
work who are basically working in that
field who no longer will use the term AI
because it's so confusing so they might
be doing so there are people who are
trying to say build artificial general
intelligence or trying to build
um AI with very very broad capacities
and other people who are working on
really discrete issues like for example
um using a using AI to improve reading
of medical images accuracy of how you
diagnose Cancers and so on but I know a
lot of those people but there's big
divisions ideologically within people
working on this a lot of those people
now just prefer to talk about machine
learning rather than AI because I think
it can be helpful
it's always it's important to break up
different ways of looking at it so we
can think about AI in terms of the
ideology of what we're actually calling
artificial intelligence
um we can also think about the actual
mechanisms of software involved we can
think about the hardware and how it's
infiltrating our infiltrating our lives
and the infrastructure so they can all
operate on different kinds of levels so
even one question even is whether or not
how it got called artificial
intelligence uh so which is in a sense a
sort of um
historically it dates from a
summer school in 1956 at Dartmouth where
John McCarthy intercept of like a school
of people got together because they
thought they'd be able to build like an
intelligent machine over a summer so
hilarious really and so that's how the
name stuck but a lot of people don't
really like the name because
intelligence has got so such broad
connotations and a lot of things is
really really discreet but the chat for
chat GPT is is is really interesting so
thinking about what what what happened
one of the things that jbt the reason
why it's so interesting is because
unlike for example using AI to diagnose
cancer but Chad GPT is doing is that
it's a chatbot it's interacting with
humans and it's interacting with the
public which means that it's not an
elite question of of asking ourselves
you know what is this doing where are we
pointing this no it's it's it's
basically loosed on to the public and
it's acting really in all kinds of ways
that are unpredictable maybe they are
predictable but it's becoming you know
really I think it's becoming something
like a form of divination for people and
people are treating it that way yeah
yeah it's just it is it's kind of
becoming a sort of better way of kind of
reading your horoscope isn't it and
trying to find answers find answers to
things so but I think it's really
interesting to think about the question
about the fact that chat gbt is about
language because not I mean not all AI
is about language but I think it's
really easy to fall into thinking
um maybe this is conscious it's really
an agent simply because of the fact that
it's focused on linguistic intelligence
which is only one aspect of intelligence
so I think one of the things that's
going on is that we're drawn towards
some of the things going on with AI I
sort of emanate from Ai and some are
about General things in the culture in
the air which feed around in a circle
and then help to shape how we're
thinking of AI so focusing focusing on
intelligence
is is is really really closely connected
to sort of like Cartesian Notions of the
mind and a body thinking about what we
are essentially is just a mental
substance and focusing very much on
cognition as a Hallmark of humans and in
particular even the cognitive all
cognition is not language in particular
thinking of linguistic skills and and
and falling fall in fact actually
because I had so many different things
we could talk about actually I actually
where did I write it down I wrote down a
club at the sketch sketch of a sort of
feedback there are feedback loops so I
was like I was really interested in your
video you did about a month ago about Ai
and Monarch about how it's a form of
agency which I think you're right about
that but I think it can be really
interesting to break it down and see how
it's operating yeah in some ways it acts
as a kind of ever escalating feedback
loop but there also are ways in which
it's operating on us as agents and it's
getting us to carry along with it like a
kind of like you know for example like
you can get funguses but infect ants
that make the ants behave weirdly and
they go up and die and spread the fungus
that thing but also one of the things
that's happening I think is that it's
breaking things down in a way that
if we're thinking really carefully it
gives us capacity to go back and see
hang on this is wrong
um this is not this is not working we
can go back and see what the problem is
so if we if we take the General Life let
me just illustrate it kind of operates a
bit like I think it operates it can
operate a bit like I was using a
metaphor of how bushfires spread so so
they can spread in Australia where I
used to live I know they can spread
really really rapidly one reason is
because you get the eucalyptus gas
um forming Balls of Fire that leap ahead
but then after the fire there's kind of
Devastation but for there are eucalyptus
trees that will only Sprout from seed if
they've been through a fire so that
things can can come up so it's kind of
like a cycle of things but but that are
that are happening so if we go back to
the notion that some people are trying
to build AI to be like a God and there's
Theology and AI
one of one of the things that's
happening is that there's a response to
AI that we need to try to combat it so
we need to think about like the ethics
of AI so we need to have ways of trying
to think about that and
one of the problems with that one of the
problems of ways of trying to think
about that is that the standard ways
we've been thinking about ethics kind of
break down
so that you can think about ethics in
terms of broadly in terms of harms and
benefits across the population
but we can't just carry on with old
Notions of homes and benefits because
what we think of as a harm and what we
think of as a benefit is changing
because of technology and so so like a
basis I'm like a really popular commonly
used way of looking at ethics a
utilitarian model would be based upon we
need to try to fulfill human desires
and to try to work out what our desires
really are you know not our kind of
short-term desires but what are higher
higher end desires are but what AI is
doing is hacking our desires it's
working on us as an object in hackigon
so what that then means is that this
ethical basis of simply looking at
fulfilling our desires or what makes us
happy cannot be used we should
understand it cannot be used which means
we then had to go to try to think really
clearly and what the basis of our values
are which can end up going back to
thinking we need to think about God or
certainly some higher value yeah so you
sort of mean by the
have I explained it okay yeah you can
kind of get a loop where we do actually
have to so yeah so yeah so yeah so we
have to think about
we end up having to think about not just
some superficial notion of Ethics but
about human nature where we are in the
universe because of the fact it's being
taken apart by AI so so I I I'm a bit
pessimistic and a bit optimistic but I
think we need to think really carefully
about it but have I explained it okay no
I think I think you I think you've
explained it well
um
yeah let me let me let me think about
what you said one of the issues that AI
is doing and it's something like it's
what technology does in general yes is
that it increases power and it
externalizes
uh the the means right it's like so you
have these means of action and those
means get externalized and yes but the
the intention is usually always in the
person right so a car makes you more
powerful makes you go faster but you
need to add things to you and to what
what AI seems to be doing and it's it's
not just AI it's in general uh
Information Technology seems to have
been doing that for a while is that it
it's externalizing thinking
um and externalizing the Very process of
of thinking and what you need to get to
the to the so you can remain with a
desire let's say or a question but the
the means by which you get to the answer
is now completely can be completely
externalized yes you need no you need to
and so and at the very least when AI
seems to be able to do is to increase
our power in a way that will also
atrophy the the muscle of intelligence
that humans have yeah and so then that
bigger question like you asked like what
it is to what does it mean to be human
yeah and then also what does it mean to
be happy like what is it that are we
just people who want the kick like we
just want we just want it to happen or
do the very process of being involved in
something is part of what gives us
meaning and purpose yeah yeah precisely
so
at least when people talk about oh
technological unemployment and they'll
be you don't need to do any work anymore
they're going to be working they're
going to be building all this they they
work because they enjoy it I mean they
work products and they think the rest of
us are just going to sit around doing
nothing but it so depends on what it is
that you want to do there are some there
are some things where it's kind of like
like if you need to do organize lots of
numbers it's really handy to be able to
do it fast to Outsource that but the
other things we want to do it ourselves
I mean what's the first thing kids start
saying is that I want to tie my own
shoelaces up they want to be able to do
it stuff yourself so that's that's it's
taking us away but it's also it is
actually atrifying us so do so that's
what chat GPT is doing it doesn't do it
on its own so so of course for example
the first people immediately people in
education were really worried because it
immediately people started cheating on
their essays right away I mean it's like
my kids found out about it in five
minutes and they knew you exactly how to
use it and it was like in all their
classmates know how to use it so and
yeah yeah but if but if you think about
you but you think if you think about the
incentives for doing that why would you
be incentivized to cheat on an exam it's
only because uh education what's
happened in education the idea that
education is about getting a formal
certificate so you can prove that you
can do it together The Next Step not
about actually wanting to learn it for
your own sake if you really wanted to if
you really wanted to learn I mean like
when you learn carving you you didn't
think I wish I could just get it done by
a machine did you yeah no at least that
myself yeah yeah you use a value of
doing it but what so what it's doing to
our language so it's so it's
so it's to understand language for sure
more than that it's it's controlling our
language so through through I don't know
if I'm a chat GTP but also language in
general online it's being censored
because of no sensitive control for
so-called misinformation uh
misinformation actually usually based
upon a totally bogus knowledge of a
model of what science is because you
know all scientific knowledge is up for
grabs
um it's also actual being our capacity
to to learn language you know you just
have to use spell check or something but
also it's also imposing a kind of
uniformity on us uniformity or language
so actually so
actually I wrote a book recently I wrote
a book can I advertise my book sure of
course okay came up a couple of months
ago AI ethics all right hey artistics
yeah it came out a couple of months ago
which is I wrote it as a I wrote it as a
I should I should give you the
information okay the Springer it came
out with it's uh look it's really long
it's it's like I wrote it as a textbook
um to try to sort of uh
put lots of ideas together but a reason
why I mentioned it now is because the
Publishers decided that they're going to
use an AI Editor to edit it
I couldn't believe that I couldn't
believe it and I thought my neighbor was
going to call the police because I was
like shouting into my computer so much
you just couldn't believe what it did to
it but one of the really interesting
things is
I could choose between whether I wanted
to use British spelling or American
spelling I'll use British spelling which
meant I use British English and it
really made me realize there are massive
differences between American English and
British English and this AI couldn't
tell the difference it just put
everything into American English which
from offense to American English but
it's really different and it kept change
it kept changing my meaning it just
really kept changing my grammar but the
present tense is used slightly
differently I didn't even realize that
it really mucked it all up but but chat
GPT I asked chat GPT if it knows the
difference between different forms of
English because Indian English again is
different and then the regional dialects
in Britain no it doesn't it had no idea
so maybe it does now because I because I
asked it but so what that means it's
doing it's looking at all the stuff in
English and just collating it into an
amorphous mass of English yeah so
different ways of using English are all
being collated into one and then there's
stuff online
I think chat gbt is stops at collecting
data at 2021 I think but if it carries
on updating the data it's going to be
collecting its own data it's going to be
like it's going to be a feedback loop
there's a that's a that's the really
that's really the biggest thing that I'm
seeing is that if you project AI very
long term it's got It's going to be
diminishing it'll be diminishing returns
and a kind of
you know when people when people talk
about like Singularity and like AI you
know exploding and becoming I don't see
I don't see how that's possible because
it has no relevance it has no desires
and so all it can ultimately be is a
kind of spinning back onto itself with
maybe with a long Arc but on that long
Arc you're looking at a kind of of
leveling you know a kind of intelligence
leveling I don't see I can't see
otherwise yes yes yeah I know so it's
good it's going to be the same way so
like in in in music but apparently half
a music is set up online I don't know
much of the technical details it's it's
set to a particular sort of calibration
based on keyboards and and so it's it's
just it's a limited way of looking at
the music so if it's it all ends up
online it's the same with everything
language is just going to and I asked
chat PT about it isn't this a problem
and it just replied it was actually
quite funny I was asking check GPT about
AI ethics it's quite funny
it's kind of like a way of skimming the
surface of how bad things are
um it just replies lied by saying that
although human language has always
evolved but this is going to stop it
evolving isn't it and it's always
evolved in different ways it's always
evolved in in really different ways I
mean because yeah it's different because
it can't because it's not referring to
anything that's the problem it does it
has no relevance and that's and I think
and but then I don't know if you listen
to the discussion that if you saw John
viveki's video on AI I still need to
talk to him about it uh explicitly but
he he said the only solution to AI is
embodiment and not just embodiment but
biological embodiment in that so that it
attains relevance yeah I completely
agree actually I mean I've listened to
some of this stuff but I just think
that's I think one of the big problems
one of the big problems is how it's
making us less and less embodied so
partly through that's partly why I said
we should think about
um how we're thinking of what AI is the
ideology of it so that because
so it's interesting how we think about
intelligence as soon as we start
thinking about AI is intelligent based
on its use of language mostly we then
start thinking if it's intelligent
therefore maybe it's like us maybe it's
an agent but intelligence is just one
one aspect of who we are yeah
manifest manifested all sorts of
embodied ways yeah no you know but I
think I think our intuition we did we
talked about this a long time ago where
we talked about how the systems seem to
be farming intelligence from humans and
then basically yes acting as a extension
of that farmed intelligence that seems
to be more and more true because most of
the eyes now are what they call hybrid
AIS which means that they're trained by
humans using different methods like
mid-journey is a is training you know
because people the mid Journey will
select will produce several images and
then you will choose which one to have
majority refined and so as you're doing
that you're constantly telling it what's
good and what's bad and so it seems like
that that notion of uh that notion that
that AI is basically not intelligent or
agendic the way that we think about it
but that it's it's farming it from
humans yes yeah it's also doing in terms
of the hardware because in order to do
that its hardware and the hardware is
most the hardware is mostly Main made by
people working in really awful
conditions I think sometimes under
conditions of slavery or what's
effectively slavery kids in a Congo
digging up minerals with their bare
hands and people in China working in
really important conditions so so that's
another way in which it's hacking
Humanity so that it's so it's so
interestingly actually
um one of one of the ways in which is
also um hacking our agency is in resp is
in responses to it to try to control try
to control it you know sometimes through
like controlling what language people
can say online and so on but also
through uh through through legislation
so um the European Union has got an AI
act which is just about to go through
but they've been
for working on for a couple for two or
three years
to try to try to reduce the harms of AI
so focusing on it's focusing on it spoke
it's focusing on because because AI can
cover lots of different things so it
starts up we're trying to define AI and
then it's focusing on trying to
legislate about AI if it's going to
cause you know sort of serious or or
major harms but for Preamble The
Preamble to the ACT written written by
written by the uh gonna sound a bit
brexity now the unelected Ursula Van Der
Laden who's holding the European union
says that it's important to have
legislation to control AI to build
public trust in AI
so but we couldn't so that we can
advance Innovation so that we can
increase the uptake of innovation so
it's focused on human rights but it's
focused on the human rights of people
within the European Union because if
you're going to increase Innovation
you're going to increase the hardware
which is mostly outsourced to people in
the rest of the world who are working in
really terrible conditions yeah yeah but
also I mean the idea that we the reason
is because we want to build public trust
and AI that's the reason why we're doing
it it's like we AI is a given it's going
to take over and so now we want to build
public trust and AI you know my daughter
who's 15. she she received an email from
the government from the the education
uh Ministry of Education uh and it was
asking her to fill out a quiz online
like uh you know a questionnaire online
and you know it said that you could win
50 or whatever
and the questionnaire was from the
government asking her about Ai and what
they were doing is asking her what they
think about AI uh school counselors
for psychological issues well yeah
that's where we are think about it
because and in the questionnaire it was
basically suggesting that you know this
this AI counselor would not have any
prejudices wouldn't be racist wouldn't
be sexist right and yeah exactly yeah it
would it would be able to avoid all the
prejudices of a human uh uh counselor
well for one thing that's a complete lie
because it's going to have
built it yeah but they'll be the right
people that built that put those you
know they'll be the non-hate prejudices
right
but wow but also I mean one of the
things that will be happening then it'll
be collecting data it collects data on
people all the time
constantly we're constantly so that's
another way in which it spreads that's
another way in which the ideology
spreads because of a metrics of all the
data that's been collected so so all but
all the time we're having data collected
about us and all the time data that you
thought was just ambient sort of like
junk data turns out to be data that can
tell you something about yourself or
could potentially do that so that's
another way that's another way in which
we're being sort of trained or seduced
into thinking
a sort of mentalistic conception of a
human being because you're trying to
think that we're just basically
therefore made up of information or made
up of data yeah
um but AI human counselor but also why
you might ask the question so all these
things are nested in other things going
on around them you know about cheating
on exams with chap GPT is nested in a
wider issue about competitiveness in
education and and exams and but there's
also an easy solution to that which is
um I got a really novel idea for that
you could just sit in a room at a desk
with a piece of paper and a pencil if
you wanted what people know you could do
that it's gonna be something really
novel it's never been done before yeah a
lot of it could really easily be sorted
out that kind of way but but you might
when I was at school there was no such
thing as a school counselor now maybe
there should have been maybe there were
some things but but were overlooked it
was a bit more brutal in those days but
you might start thinking why why why why
are so many school children so many
teenagers having such massive range of
mental health problems yeah
yeah there's there's definitely there's
definitely all of this is kind of
crunching at the same time which is this
Mental Health crisis with with young
people yeah
but it does have to do with AI in the
sense you know that it is the question
of what it is to be human what it is to
be part of a society what it means to be
someone in a community all these things
are exploded right now yes yeah I think
the pandemic really wasn't as well
actually yeah because lots of Technology
was introduced but just never went away
I mean lots lots and lots of things have
just been introduced and they've got all
this works fine or it's slightly better
in some way
um and so they're just keeping it but I
think all the on the online presence
again is just
encouraging us to a disembodied way of
relating to people I think we've talked
about this before but it's sort of but
you can get easy access to a sort of
so-called community
but it's just completely not the same as
actually spending time with actual
people is it but it it brings about this
idea that some ways that we are these
Cartesian disembodied thing there is a
rift between your mind your your
identity and your body you know this is
accelerated so much because the thing is
that even this conversation I mean it's
fine as a conversation but I've noticed
now because now I've done both where I
talk to someone on Zoom that I met them
in person and you know
there's all the there are all these
unconscious cues about a person that
have nothing to do with just what you
see and what you hear but you know body
position to muscle tension there's even
smells probably there's all these things
that are part of our human engagement
that that we somehow because of because
of these screens we're able to alienate
ourselves from that seems to be part of
what's feeding into the massive
alienation between our bodies and our
our identities and our minds yeah yeah
I'm gonna I mean it could be so there's
so much so much concern now about having
people who for example wanting identity
to be validated or being really upset if
you don't completely agree what their
identity is as if it's really really
fragile so I suppose but I think if if
we if you weren't just online so much if
you're with somebody you get you get
validation and a sense of belonging
simply from you know sitting and having
a cup of tea with somebody even without
speaking or just I'm sure I mean I'm
absolutely certain we pick up signals
from people we pick up because when we
pick up signals from people like we have
electrical fields that go running a long
way for our bodies I'm sure that's one
of the ways in which we we are
interconnected and have a sense
animals like we're we're human animals
we have bodies animals you know they
smell each other they they have like as
if we don't have any of those we're just
these these exactly just like these eyes
and these this mind yes but but that's
it that is definitely that's definitely
part of the whole issue of what's going
on and the fact that we're able to
conceive AI as being
similar or even Superior to us in terms
of what of intelligence and in terms of
agency means that we we are deeply
misunderstanding what it is to be a
person yes yes yeah yeah precisely so
there's another aspect of work but I do
but when we're looking really closely
into this did I mention my work I do
some work part-time with a group of
sociologists we look at the care of
people with dementia in particularly in
hospitals so so what are one of the
things we're really really really
I'm concerned about is
it so it's not it's not to deny the
dementia um isn't a really difficult
condition that can cause lots of
cognitive issues but it's to try to sort
of fight back up about the idea that
we're simply
cognitive creatures and there's lots and
lots of work that indicates that people
have got can even one even after they've
lost almost all language can retain a
real strong sense of where they are in a
community on a power to behave and a
sense of belonging and understanding
with other people and often mediated
through things like so so a lot of work
we've done in my colleagues have done in
hospitals looks at looks at things like
um even the clothing that people wear so
that especially if you have dementia if
you have if you're dressed in your own
familiar clothing it helps to give you a
sense of where you are and who you are
let's look much much less likely to have
their own clothing on we found much more
likely just to be in hospital down adapt
for men not to be shaved lose their
glasses and so on so it's that it's that
that sense of of embodied belonging or
just left in beds left in bed a person
could be transformed if they're taken
out of bed and just sit and have a cup
of tea with somebody yeah it's not it's
not that's not just that happens with
people with dementia that happens
for for all of us yeah well the image of
the old person you know sitting on their
porch on their rocking chair this is an
image that we have here in in Canada for
sure you know the idea that that person
is there but is also kind of not totally
there you know yeah but they're still
there and they still have they're still
part of life and they still have their
little routine and they do their things
and and we we kind of understand that
maybe they're kind of slipping away into
some extent but that doesn't mean like
you said that right exactly so now let's
let's put him in a hospital bed in a
hospital gown with a septic sized walls
and let's just make it all worse because
yeah because now they're not part of
anything yes yeah yes so we've got an
artist joined our team last last term
last year
um she's doing some doing some work with
painting workshops with people who are
living with dementia as a way of helping
to uh people to ex to express to express
ideas starting on some of the workshops
with her
um it's it's so it's looking at the idea
of of the materiality of a paint as a
way of as a way of actually but this is
actually a form of thinking that
expressed through the materiality of
what you can understand and communicate
and express through the actual physical
materials that you're using so so that's
that's a like a really embodied way of
being a human and and
acting something out yeah but you can
see it like here in Canada especially
all of these things are definitely
related because you know the the Scandal
around made here around medical
assistant dying is I mean it's now it's
blowing up because I think it's just
been a few years since it's become legal
and I think it's 30 000 people have been
have have gone through made and so you
can see that it is this idea that you I
mean just this this very idea that
exactly you're this thing and then at
some point you decide all right now's my
time to to die because it's all
cognitive it's all it's all mental and
so then you just decide and then you die
and it's like it really is this
reduction of the human person to to the
to to this conscious abstract conscious
being yeah yeah I mean it's also related
to the use of Technology as well yeah
that's one of the things that's
happening is it you think that every
problem must have a technological
solution or if you have a bit of
Technology you must use it often so that
every every look every
yeah
every desire must be fulfilled every
every time if you're if you have like
this much pain that has to be taken away
yeah and you can imagine that AI is
going to be perfect for this because you
know you can take away the guilt or the
or the problem ethical problem of the
doctors having to make certain decisions
where it's just the eye is going to
decide who gets to live and who gets to
die and it'll be an objective decision
uh you know it's all good it's just like
the AI counselor you know no Prejudice
no no none of the human foibles no guilt
no yes
yes but but
probably will happen but that is a that
is a way of also Outsourcing
responsibility because that would only
happen within the context of a of a
medical profession where you know people
still for some unknown reason tend to
trust doctors
they're still there's still an aura that
this is somehow Healthcare yes how we
get how it gets labeled does help
there's health care if they did it in a
butcher shop that might be
movies
a better idea of what was actually
happening yeah so what the doctors at
least here are almost already reduced to
machines you know if you go to the
doctor now all they do is sit in front
of computer and fill out a fill out a
report as they're talking to you right
yeah they're sitting in their computer
and they're filling out the report and
so you know they're already just
basically data Gathering
uh that's all they're doing and you know
their decision is kind of kind of handed
down by the system yeah and so you know
it's just it's just a question of time
really uh before yeah before this
becomes more and more automated
thank you yeah yeah it's not I'm I'm
definitely not a short-term Optimist on
all these fronts
well yeah but I
I'm there is the use of metrics and also
the idea that these I.T systems are
actually going to save time we've been
told that we've been told that over and
over and over and over again it's going
to save time whereas I can but I can
remember when I first started as a
lecturer you would just like write your
reading list out
on a piece of paper and give it to
somebody to type we have we have so much
more work to do but the metrics the
metrics and so one of the things that
metric's doing is capture it and then
the information belongs to this belongs
to the institution so that's a way of
rolling things so I've noticed you know
I've noticed that you know people who
explicitly told that management can read
your emails so you must notice that
everyone's being really polite about oh
we've got this change of University
going to be really good yeah because you
know because they're going to read your
emails
um so yeah when you wrote something on a
piece of paper and you gave it to
someone then nobody could read it
obviously yeah yeah so so that's how
it's how it's controlled but it's also
it's always done in terms of it's just
going to say this is going to save you
time it's going to save time somebody
say they could introduce AI into
medicine because then the doctors will
have more time for like communicating
with the patients yeah of course
obviously that's what's going to happen
we all know that it's going to lead to
doctors spending more time with patients
my goodness it's not it's not going to
happen there's no way that it's going to
happen but everything also it's just
produced to metrics that's one of the
way which the AI is also you know is
also controlling us by if students are
reduced to metrics then what gets
measured is what we look at yeah if if
you if you reduce things to sort of
harms and benefits it depends on how you
measure them so what do you think about
in the Molag video what I was trying to
present clearly and it's not me who came
up with this obviously that's in the
moloch problem itself is that we're so
focused on the ai's agency and the fact
whether or not AI becomes a
Consciousness or whatever that we
forget that we stop noticing the way
that it's actually acting on us which is
sometimes outside of the software
outside of the hardware but rather in
the very competition to implement so so
the the us as agents we are in a
competition to implement AI because we
know that whoever implements it will
have an advantage and so it's almost
like an evolutionary race towards the
implementation of AI and so the agency
seems to that agency seems much stronger
than the question of whether or not the
software and the hardware or whatever
become conscious
yeah well yes I mean there is a kind of
balance right there's lots of there's
lots of different sorts of arms races
going on so what uh one of the one of
the problems that like like all ordinary
people have is working out what they can
do about it and I think there's a there
can be on the one hand you could say
there's not much we can do about it but
I think there's a there's a sort of a
there's a kind of a danger of thinking
this is going to be some big crisis so
just let's wait for the crisis and then
something will happen but I I kind of
think they're still wait there's still
ways in which there's still ways in
which people can be aware of what's
going on and try to get a bit more
control in their life because I mean one
of the things that AI is going to do and
this is something that I'm noticing
already you know we're doing this this
snow white project and uh and we're
going to see is going to be
uh
a deliberate focus on human
intentionality will become will happen
so it's not just that AI people think
that AI is gonna like take over art but
I don't think so I think that there'll
be even a more of a fetishization of the
art object with AI because it'll become
very precious you know this idea of the
actual someone making something will
will have a kind of aura that that uh
you know that all the the like
let's say the wave the drowning wave of
mid-journey images and of AI generated
images won't have so people will will
coagulate will kind of rally around
intention uh more and so that's a
hopeful aspect of what AI seems to be
bringing
yeah yes
will lead to a turn to people actually
wanting more
what will happen a bit I mean because
why do people
I mean why do people actually go to
galleries to see
you know try try to get to see the Mona
Lisa you can't get anywhere near it
because people don't want to people want
to go and see the actual the actual
thing don't they I mean the galleries
are just absolutely absolutely crowded
and so many so many people will be are
are really Keen to own a piece of art
yeah but some people painted even if
it's not even it's not like
you might think it's not terribly good
they gonna love they just love it
because somebody has actually made it I
think there's going to be a move to
people I mean there is a move to people
like doing performing performing new
live music I mean because I mean live
music like tinned music is just nothing
nothing like just nothing like live
performance but also even in terms of
even in terms of um online censorship
and people being you know permanently
canceled from things there are people
people are beating up so you know so
people are you know people are going no
I know in London people are going to
they're being canceled from so many
different things but their views on
various things people think you're going
to standard speakers call now yeah so
you've got the police protect you you
can say whatever you want yeah so
there's when you talk about live music
and I think that that's a good example
to help people understand the difference
is that when you go to an event where
there's people there is a kind of
electricity I don't know what it is but
there is a kind of electricity that
develops a kind of of
um feeling of participating in a in a
group and participating in a movement
participating in a a wave that's going
through that you cannot have you just
cannot have that when you're sitting at
a screen and so that that that will not
go away you know the goggles if you get
the the VR goggles they're not going to
provide that kind of that kind of uh
electricity that you get from going to a
sports game or going to just can't no no
because I I've heard you've talked
before about with a bit of skepticism
about like concerts and with a
comparison between well for sure I think
concerts are Downstream from yeah from
from real participative actions like you
know like whether it's folk dancing or
religious participation they're
Downstream from that but they they still
have a level of reality that is
undeniable yeah yes precisely so if you
I mean if you go if you if you if you go
to see I mean actually I've been um I've
been to some fantastic operas recently
when you get back up you can't sleep for
hours you can't because it's just but
there are also there are levels of
participation in those sorts of things
as well yeah because a lot of people who
go to vote don't know a lot about the
performers spend her bill you know join
some Society where they can go backstage
there's all sorts of levels of
participation but but yeah I think I
think that's the way that's a way to go
actually actually meeting up actually
meeting up with with people
um uh there's some do you know I haven't
talked to you before I mentioned it's a
really interesting person who works in
VR called I hope I pronounce his name
correctly Geron Lanier
l-a-n-i-e-r is pronounced I think so
he's one of the people who've actually
developed VR but he's got some really
interesting stuff to say um one of the
things you might find he's got some
videos online and a number of books and
one of the things he says about there
they are is the best thing about it is
taking the headset off because then it
makes you realize how absolutely
fantastic reality is
yeah because the amount of colors the
amount of depth like if you look through
if you look at you know I was walking
today this morning when you look at the
sun like come through the leaves and in
a wooded area you can have as much you
can have as much resolution on your 4K
whatever
it's just not you just can't compare it
because you know also you don't get like
you say you don't get the smell you
don't get feeling the heat coming you
know from from the sky you don't have
all these Sensations that are so rich
when you
yeah that's something else I've noticed
as well actually so in order to
counteract so much awful stuff online I
joined lots of lots of lots of kind of
like Facebook groups like Welsh lands
great photography like the corrugated
iron Appreciation Society things like
that just post photos of stuff and then
people started posting posting AI photos
and things people can tell straight up
it's really quickly tell right away like
yeah I don't know like they keep telling
us that at some point we won't be able
to tell the difference between Ai and
and real photos but I'm not sure at
least you know when they posted those
pictures of the Pope everybody got
tricked by these pictures of the Pope
like you could just tell that it was a I
don't know there's a there's a subtle
difference in the way that that there's
something about it I mean maybe at some
point we won't be able to tell but at
least for now it's quite still very easy
to tell it's just like with GPT a lot of
people said oh this is really fantastic
it gets his answers it gave it really
are really great but you can if you just
keep on answering it you can tell that
it's you can tell but it's just
because it avoids it's low level
whatever it's just basically it can
synthesize some some things like in
tempted to be able to synthesize some
some uh some ideas but they're very it's
very superficial yes I mean the other
thing as well actually even if the end
result is the same or already close
enough to be good enough for what you
want
it it hasn't it hasn't got to the end
result in anything like the same way
yeah in constructing it and constructing
an an image or doing a really good like
AI painting or something it hasn't been
it hasn't spent years in life drawing
class
yes but it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't
look at the figure and sort of you know
it
a drawing class and it'll well there'll
be different techniques for sort of
thinking about you know how you might
think about what it is equal seeing and
how you might see it doesn't do any of
that it doesn't do any of that at all so
so in terms of saying it's intelligence
it could it can do it can do things and
achieve a result but whether it's
whether it's intelligence the same sort
of way as us it's so it's a really
difficult question to fall in and so for
chat gbt it just it just predicts what
the next word is likely to be it is like
that no but what's interesting about
about that is you know because the
people who are programming
Ai and the people that are putting it
together and amassing all this insane
amount of language data and then pumping
it into these to these algorithms that
are predicting uh the future they don't
understand they don't think they totally
know what's encoded in human language it
is it is true that some of the very very
deep aspects of human consciousness will
necessarily be encoded in the structures
of languages but the fact that that's
true doesn't mean that those that are
playing with this know what they're
playing with like they're playing with
these very dangerous tools yeah and some
things are going to come out of AI that
nobody will be able to predict because
because they're not aware of what the
very very strange and deep uh drives
that exist within the human
consciousness and also then ultimately
are hidden in human language so that's
why it's you know when I talk about the
idea that the AI is is like you know the
body of a fallen angel you know people I
know that some people struggle able to
to understand what I'm saying you think
I'm just talking about mythological
images and and yeah of course the
mythological mythological images
captured very well but in terms
technically you can understand it that
way is to say that you don't know what's
in human language you don't know what
all the motivators are you don't know
what all the hidden structures are that
that make that underlying meaning and so
we're just playing with this and we're
kind of tossing the dice and and tossing
it around but there are agencies in
there that are very dark the type of
agencies that made Human Sacrifice other
humans the type of agencies that made
you know people commit genocide all
these agencies are there in the very
structure of human language and and the
fact that people don't seem to totally
understand that I mean probably the raw
version of Chad gbt has it all and now
they're just trying to patch over it to
stop that stuff from leaking out but
it's like it's probably there in the Raw
version of of the of open AI all that
stuff is probably bubbling up all the
time
Yeah well yeah I mean there's there's so
many attempts to try to try to work out
ways of General ways of trying to
control AI so so what I think I might
have mentioned it to you before was it
Stuart Russell for example for example
has written a book called human
compatible which is supposed to be a
response to Nick bostrom's book on super
intelligence so Nick Boston wrote this
book a while ago now actually I think
2015 or 16. about he's a paper kit he's
a paperclip guy yeah about how to
control super intelligence Stuart
Russell is he's like a real AI expert
like he knows what he's talking about he
wrote he wrote the major textbook on AI
co-rudge it he's he's got an idea but we
should try to make certain but but AI
but we're producing has is aligned with
what humans want
but then the problem is what do humans
want you record right do you know what
humans were he recognizes that problem
so here's his here's his solution which
is it's this which is absolutely
terrible it's honestly Asian s just
stick with their eye and stop doing this
it's absolutely terrible because he
thinks we should try to train AI to
observe human behavior and extrapolate
from from our Behavior
honestly he's got a book on his foot
look it's got a book he did he did like
a set of lectures on the BBC a year or
two ago on it it's an extrapolate from
my behavior what what it is that we
really want what it is that we really
want yeah what's that going to be what
is that I mean
but also could you even interpret you
could probably interpret human behavior
in in any loads and loads of different
ways what do you what do you
what do you really want I mean maybe or
maybe our darkest desires are really our
stronger ones right yeah that's right
exactly maybe maybe the the
drive towards murder and War and rape
and all these things they're there I
don't know what to tell you the idea
that you would just watch and you would
just extrapolate from human language and
human behavior it's just not
that's just not gonna fly yeah you know
that was like P.S please exclude all
Hannibal lecture types and then also
exclude yeah but there's a but there's a
narrative so there's a narrative in
human society you know which which is
encapsulated in the murder of Socrates
or the murder of Christ which is that
that human quality is found in in
exactly that in
not in the quantity it's found in the in
these exceptional shining bright lights
that we look to and we align ourselves
on but that most of the stuff is all
this really chaotic dark stuff so so the
idea that you would extrapolate you know
mathematically uh you know or
statistically from human behavior is
insane that's a crazy thing because I'm
like a really really strong motivator
for human beings is enemy isn't it so
that if you want to be like if you want
to be like if you want to be
um picked if you want to be like picked
for something there's two ways of doing
it one is to make yourself better than
the others and the other is just to
knock the others down because then
you're the one who's picked so Envy is
such a unbelievably strong motivator so
that if if it picked on that where would
we be where would we be would just be
just knocked down that's not the problem
yeah and especially and what's
interesting about the the 10 gpts and
the AIS the way they're being trained
now is that they're trained on on
attention grabbing mechanism they're
trained on the internet they're trained
on all these things these social media
platforms these are the these are really
the worst place because because they're
only there to get your immediate
attention yes you tend to immediately
default to the most immediate you know
uh Pleasures that we can find you know
which are you know Envy all these things
that's what people are you know rage
anger lust all these passions are the
ones driving these platforms yes yes so
so I mean one of the things you could
say about
about AI acting as a kind of super
agency is you can kind of turn it on its
head and sort of think what the
character what a broad common
characteristics of agents and and in
terms of common characteristic human
agents is to actually try to manipulate
and dehumanize other people so
manipulate people by dehumanizing so
that's what the ideally that's what age
we should treat each other you know as
Emmanuel Kant said and others have said
you know we should always strive to
treat other people as an end in
themselves and never Milly as a means
but but something like the Stuart
Russell setup is actually built into it
but the AI has been asked to treat the
human as a means as a means to finding
out what the humans want so it's looking
at us from like from a third person
perspective like a like a behaviorist
would
looking at our behavior from from the
outside so that's one of the things
that's happening in the agency is that
we're seeing it as an agent partly
because some people think it must be an
independent agent of its own but also
because we're actually we're allowing it
to dehumanize us by focusing our
attention on something but to avoid
something else yeah but but also but the
wider The Wider metrics that are using
for what effect is measuring stuff it
means there's some things it's not
measuring so that's left out so we just
focused on what's measurement the thick
the thing that actually the one thing
that I'm afraid one day I'm gonna be
like arrested for shouting at somebody
in the street the thing but but really
really upsets me is parents of small
children who are just looking at their
phones and not talking to their children
it's like it's actually not funny
because human babies
I'm actually going to get really upset
human babies and little kids are
designed they're designed to grab our
attention yeah they need it they need it
to survive because they don't know how
the people say but they also need it for
language development cognitive
development they need constant
interaction not constant but you know
yeah
I don't know where it's like you see
there's so many parents who are just
looking at their phones and not looking
at their kids yeah well you see that in
parks and I remember even before I I had
a phone really late before I had a phone
I would go play with my kids in the park
and I would watch parents sitting on the
bench with their phones yeah yeah but
another thing it does it isolates us
from each other in ridiculous in
ridiculous so here's can I give you a
lot just one really stupid if you look
at these tiny little examples tiny
little examples you can sort of think
about oh yeah that's happening in my
life and just not do it so I went from
being in a pub with some friends last
week and the blue we went to pay proudly
announced that they don't it's not just
that they only take cards they pay by QR
code so for one thing if you hadn't got
a smartphone you couldn't pay so but
that also meant that the one person who
was paying had to scam is it proudly
saying oh it's really good for the
environment because we don't have a
paper Bill instead of having a little
scrappy tidy bit of paper bill they came
out carried out a card a nice little
Posh card with the Pub's name on printed
on both sides in color so they're like
so he's blatantly lying is it how it's
like a Conjuring trick lying to your
face that they're saving paper because
he's come out with a piece of paper and
then the person who was paying her to
scan it onto his phone so nobody else
can see the bill and he's had trouble
doing it so the lie was this is quicker
it took longer because he had trouble
looking at how to do it and then we paid
and then remembered but one of the
things we'd ordered hadn't been
available so we wanted to try and check
did we get charged because of our cheese
that we didn't have couldn't check
because it's vanished
and then the waiter was just like
boasting boasting boasting about it do I
say listen mate read my book you know
yes it's just honestly but that's when
you wonder what the hell is driving this
because it's the same even just the
menus you go into a restaurant and then
instead of just giving you a plastic
menu they give you a QR code you have to
scan the QR code and then you're like on
your phone trying to figure out the menu
it's so ridiculous yes and it's like but
it's so much more complicated like why I
don't understand like like I do
understand but you know it's interesting
to notice that it doesn't necessarily
make things
easier it's just some fetishization of
the process yeah it's a specialization
of progress so it must be progress
because you're using technology uh it's
also excluding people I mean like this
is my phone proudly this is my phone I
couldn't have paid I don't have to do
the washing up so um but but it's so
excluding people because then so my
friends always ridiculed me for that
phone but so so that people get picked
on and ridiculed but it's also excluding
people because if you had the whole menu
you I mean usually they bring many of
them more than one people but if we'd
had a paper Bill we could all have
looked to say oh look they've charged us
for qualified but we can't we can't it's
just one one person looking at it it
puts you into that little kind of like
all these times it's set souls to us a
saving time now yes sometimes saving a
tiny bit of time is is what you want
like if you're a pit stop in a Grand
Prix or if you're trying to save
somebody's life in ICU at incremental
difference an incremental difference you
know that can be incredibly save more
people's lives but when did anybody go
to a restaurant and think the real
problem is that it takes 30 seconds to
pay the bill I want to pay it in 25
seconds yeah what do you think that yeah
yeah yeah yeah so but yeah so so what do
you think I mean what do you think are
some of the ways because it seems like
I mean AI is is taking over there's no
doubt about it like there's no way
around it really and so what are the
ways do you think that we can
engage with it or not engage with it you
know that find ways to kind of stay as
human as possible in this context
well
I've got to think I'd probably say the
similar things things similar things to
you really but we just we need to do as
much as stuff as much stuff as possible
in in the in the real world yeah and but
but also take the take the time and a
chance to sort of think really seriously
about what it is to be a human being
but you know to join in you know to join
in community to join in rituals to sort
of see to you know to see people as much
as possible to spend as much time
spend as much time
as you can in nature because wherever
you are you could find a bit of nature
um
but also just really just really think I
mean one of the things you can do is
just stop just kind of stop rubbing your
friends for for not that's one of the
things that's happening people people
get people joined in or or just oh for
example you can just point you know
maybe write to institutions and point
things out so but I noticed for example
the QR code men is the National Gallery
in London most of all most all the other
places you can get a paper map and you
might have to pay a pound for it you can
get a paper map of the museum and then
with your friends you can say which
galleries you want to go to we can have
a little look and carry it around with
you the National Gallery you have to
have a QR code on your smartphone now so
so you could maybe I should do that at
the end of this right to the National
Gallery and say look you shouldn't do
this for one thing it's got disability
of occasions because not everybody can
read stuff on the smartphone you know
it's too so small yeah it's a ridiculous
thing it's like it's so unpractical to
look at him to look at the map on your
smartphone yeah so but I would I would
just I would just suggest I think just
look at how it's just become integrated
into the infrastructure of everything
you do and just just ask yourself is
that what you
I mean like maps for example there's
some really undermining people's
capacity to
do oh I was I was walking somewhere the
other day in London and we it's a
slightly confusing area because the
streets just go out at different angles
and we had to try to get to some
pancreas it's always sort of heading
north it's fine so how do you know we're
heading north well because of the
Shadows on the buildings it's West over
there but
it's it's
uh sorry it's just it but just just look
that's why I think it's like important
to think about what the agency is doing
in really kind of minute little details
because that's the only only place
that's the only place we have to try to
yeah yeah right try to think about
unless you happen to be you know have a
have
some particular position
um hmm
yeah all right all right let's take that
as a lesson for today
so so Paula where can people get your
book if they are interested in your in
your textbook is it possible to get it
somewhere online or to order it no you
can get I mean you can get it it's you
can get it from um the Springer website
it's on you can get it on Amazon you can
get it on all the usual on all the usual
places it's quite expensive because it's
it's
a textbook or get or get your school or
University Library to forget it yeah so
yeah so one of the things one of the
things I've tried to do is called AI
ethics but one of the things I do is
actually explain how the standard ways
of looking at ethics just don't work
they break down we'll be looking at air
money and how you need to look at
Notions of human nature I mean I mean
there's there's stuff in there about
religion actually because I talk about
how many provisions of AI are actually
fundamentally really really religious
and we need to understand understand the
roots of that in order to understand
in order to understand what what visions
of the future are being presented to us
yeah you know what what position humans
how how it's understanding a position of
of humans I mean some some of the stuff
is
some of the stuff is like Bears uncanny
resemblance to lots of religious ideas
like the general idea that humans are
really special because we're the ones in
a position who are going to be able to
create
it's fantastic being who's going to be
the Fulfillment of the universe well one
of the things that it seems that we
could use right now is an understanding
of non-human agency and what those
non-human agencies were understood to be
like in the ancient world and this is
going to sound silly to people but yeah
fairies and all these little types of
agencies how is it that ancient people
understood them like the the demons the
Angels you know how do they see them
acting on people and how do they see
their agency kind of manifesting itself
I think that we've evacuated all these
ideas of non-human agency and now we're
basically dealing with the problem of
non-human agency but we don't have any
of the tools to to deal with them
because we don't understand them we
don't think about you know you know the
idea of
if you think about for example a fairy
tale like the Shoemaker and the elves
you know and the notion of of action
that is beyond the will of the of the of
the person it's like these these tropes
that are in fairy tales you know the
pucks and all these kind of household uh
agencies these are important in
understanding the way and the dangers of
non-human agency in our lives yeah yeah
I mean that's that's one of the dangers
of the way in which we've been encourage
you to think about the mind in a purely
sort of Cartesian mental way because we
have this illusion then but we have we
are totally in control of our minds and
that we're Justified
undermined by the constant need for
affirmations from other people but we're
just isolated from from from other
people I mean have you are you familiar
with um Canadian philosopher Charles
Taylor yeah
yeah like his like his his distinction
between the the um the buffered sense
self and of course so poor herself yeah
yeah those kinds of ideas are ones that
people were well worth well worth
thinking about in terms of we just got
this idea but we're just completely
buffered which means we're actually
we're not we're we're more poorers than
ever exactly and then as people yeah and
as people kind of join with their AI
familiar they'll have this little AI
familiar that'll be working for them you
know it's like you should you should
start to think about these old stories
again because yeah the the buffer itself
is over you know we are moving into a
very very ambiguous uh state of
relationship of identities and agencies
yeah are you going to do the elves and
the Shoemaker in one of your stories
yeah we'll see it's not part of the plan
for now but that could be an interesting
idea you know I'm trying to think about
it in terms of obviously I'm just
telling the story it really is just a
fairy tale but I do want there to be a
certain angle in it that is eluding into
some of the things that are going on now
like in Snow White we did a whole
you know host there's a whole aspect of
Snow White which is the obsession that
the queen has with the mirror and the
mirror revealing who's the most
beautiful in it and so this this whole
idea of vanity and of the cell phone and
of the you know this firming machine
that's affirming or denying your value
value uh you know it's like it's so
relevant today that you know there's a
that they there's more emphasis on that
in the way that I tell the story uh and
so I think it's the same with something
like Shoemaker and the elves I would
have to find a way to explain these kind
of agencies that are acting out you know
side and on the side of our will and how
they're there and how to deal with them
uh in a way that would be helpful for
people so yeah it's a good idea think
about it
great it's my favorite one actually yeah
I love that story definitely definitely
all right everyone so so uh so if you
can uh you can check out uh Paula's
Paul's book and thanks again for your
time and and uh your your thought about
all these crazy these crazy times I
really appreciate it thanks oh great to
talk to you all right